okay is with us in Texas hi Jorge how
are you hey mr. MC how's it going better
than I deserve how can John not help yes
sir
so I had a couple questions so first of
all you know wanted your advice on
mentioned it right now have about
250,000 dollars in debt whoa
I'm about to start I'm about to start a
medical residency um in Iowa City girl
I'll be making about I'll be making
about 60 K and my fiance will also start
as a lawyer
she will also start making about 60 K
might how much does she had we she
doesn't have anything it's all my debt
she doesn't have any debt from law
school no sir how'd she do that her
parents paid for all her school Wow
that's awesome yes sir okay cool all
right so you're getting ready to be an
MD in two years and you're making sixty
K as a resident in the meantime with 250
K right and when you're getting married
yes sir so we just got engaged about a
week ago yay congratulations so thank
you thank you so much so we're thinking
maybe within the next year and a half
two years we're getting married so we
were wondering you know with her salary
once she starts working she'll she'll
also make about 60 K should we put my 60
K straight into my $250,000 or should I
wait the four years till I finished my
residency and and you know my income
potential is gonna skyrocket and then
pay everything dad no your until you're
married she should not pay your bills
okay I should not combine finances
unless you're married all right so that
would hasten the date of the marriage if
I were in your shoes right because it
sounds like you're wanting to go ahead
and play house and so you might as well
be married okay and yeah that and and
then we can talk about 120 110 thousand
dollar household income live on as
little as possible out of that and begin
to chip away at the 250 and whatever's
left we'll go into accelerate mode when
you finish your residency get your MD
and get a much bigger paycheck right by
then her income will be up to as well so
if I were talking to a doc and
resident that were married that's how I
would do it but the quicker but I would
not advise her to pay your bills or vice
versa until you're married very very
dangerous relationally as well as
legally and financially yes sir
well what's the impetus behind an
18-month or two-year engagement well
since some start and residency in July
you know the first year of residency I'm
going to be extremely busy being on-call
you know being in the hospital a lot so
the first year I don't think we'll be
able to find a good time for us to do it
20 minutes Irma it's about the party
then yeah well I mean yeah I guess we
could do it like you said no you know
did a 20-minute ceremony I talked to her
about that but no she wants to do a
full-on celebration I don't mind you
doing a full-on celebration but it takes
a half a day other than the planning and
the money but uh but uh you know be busy
in residency and her first year as a
lawyer is going to be like nothing she's
ever experienced and for being busy and
being overwhelmed and being exhausted
you can do that unified together or you
can do that this fiance
boyfriend/girlfriend but I would if you
know just oh man stuff with three kids
that got married okay you know we had
big parties on all three of those I love
a big wedding happy to do that it sounds
like her parents might have the cash to
handle that they paid for Law School so
you know the in that case this matter
how quick can we plan the party that's
all it is and so it could be like you
start residency in July we get married
in September and you could you can plan
a really nice big wedding especially
right now because there's no weddings so
you could probably like find venues and
dance bands and everything else you want
they're probably like easy to get a hold
of right now for a real cheap yeah oh
yeah and yeah I mean so I don't know how
long it'll take you logistically to put
the the catering the videographer the
photographer the dance bands the the
preacher and the vote and the venue
together but I think I could organize
that pretty quick if if I had the budget
and I were in your shoes and I didn't
everything do between now and July
because you don't start until July so
that that's what I would do I would move
all
and then as a couple I would attack this
residency which is a high-stress thing
the first year of law school which is a
high-stress thing and begin to attack
the debt which is a high-stress thing
it's easier to do that as a couple than
it is a sorter we're married but we're
acting like it shacked up yes and I hear
couples often try to plan around
stressful events we're gonna get married
after the stress and I always want to
tell them man you don't you don't get
married around stress that's the rest of
the trajectory guys and so my what
you're saying John I'm just saying
there's no there there right so yeah go
through those hard times together as a
couple versus this and let's pretend and
stumble through and in joke in half
halfway be married ich fish man married
ish married is